speaking of volunteerism someone is
voluntarily
canceling himself a beloved voice actor
harry shearer
from the simpsons which is apparently
still on air
it's surprising to me too but it is the
sim i think the simpsons is older than
me
slight very slightly older than me so
harry shearer has been voicing
uh the role of dr hibber for
years and years and we're going on like
30 years now
but he's no longer going to do that
because you see harry shearer is white
dr hibbert is black you probably didn't
know that harry shearer is white
because he's a voice actor and dr
hibbert is a cartoon
but we are now in the era that tells you
that you cannot culturally appropriate
and so he's going to give up his 30-year
voice his voice job and he's going to
give it to
kevin michael richardson who i've never
heard who is a black
voice actor and now that's going to make
things better because white people
cannot appropriate
anyone else's culture but also white
people need to be less white
remember that's what robin d'angelo said
in that training that's
associated with coca-cola all those
diversity equity inclusion
they tell you you've got to be less
white but also you can't appropriate
anybody else's culture so
uh what are you supposed to do
are you supposed to stay perfectly still
i don't know it seems kind of white to
me
you haven't your skin looks exactly the
same so you got to do better than that
what
there's nothing you can do it's a rigged
game it's a rigged request
it's not not based in anything
actionable or anything true
if you enjoyed that video be sure to hit
the subscribe button so
everyone waiting through the wasteland
of youtube knows that we've got
the absolute top content out there